you
previously it was like our dialogue was
we build a game we ship a game and the
Nets against here now it's different at
least it's our mission to make that very
very different I mean the second the
game is our will continue will be
listening and we'll do our best to to
listen to people figure out what it is
that makes them tick and then actually
try to get into the game very fast yes
that's the the promise here right that
it will evolve that we we don't know
exactly where it's going to end we know
it's going to be fun right that's that's
our pledge I will continuously become
better and better exactly
we saw today seemed like all the best
aspects of some of the previous titles
and to see the different directions
they're going to go with that same
overarching theme is exciting best of
the past mixed with the new reimagined
in a new world still still a bit bowled
over a huge map really really big
everything just felt good everything
look good just felt good to be back in
four sevens shoes we were playing for
three or four hours I never really felt
like we got past that initial setup of
seeing all the complicated bits and
pieces that we're moving it was actually
quite fantastic i wish i had more time
with it took the best from every other
hitman game it took the best from silent
assassin to the best for contracts and
blood money and together with that day
they just made the future hitman
experience
in the new hitman game we've built what
I believe is the most detailed sandboxes
yes the levels are very large if we
wanted to build a palace like we're
doing the parents we can get you
everywhere and we can make every room
very detailed but on top of that we can
also have literally hundreds of
individuals in happening that panels
which all have their ideas about what
they want to do their goals and then
that will react with a complexity that
we have not been able to do before
having this approach of being closer to
the fans being life will open up new
gameplay features that we weren't able
to do before so when we very completely
think about contracts that's not
possible without being like I want to
modify these contracts these are
features that will come more and more
into our games and help the community to
actually play with each other not only
am I playing Paris and I'm watching what
other hitman players are doing right now
but it's also this shared excitement
that next time we'll travel to Italy in
the game countdown will appear right
Italy is about to unlock and I think
that shared excitement that we are all
going to travel to Italy this weekend is
is hugely exciting and it is far as well
here at i/o will also that I can
guarantee you that weekend we'll all be
in Italy together
I love it whenever we want something and
they actually put it in the game and I
feel like I'm listened to and the game
company really cares about its fans oh
yeah absolutely i mean i always want to
be my gameplay my experience a lot
better than the second time around
certain time forth even fit time around
so yeah I'm looking forward to it I
think it's great i think the trend that
we're seeing now is more community
engagement and the better that they can
execute on that I think the more engaged
that the bass will be yeah I think it's
a good step yeah hit my phone since the
first game and they've all been really
good with this one oh no it seems better
because it's
really interested see you know how the
game progresses what playing crew
a lot of the game day one versus date 30
vs here one is going to feel like and it
seems like it's probably going to be
pretty dynamically different getting a
game out for the actual players for the
first time that's always a very
satisfying moment that's actually what
drives the end of what I'm leaving for
what's different this time is that we
don't ship the game and then we say that
was it this time we will start the game
and that is it's called a piece of work
you